la nuit dernière pendant près de 14h à
l'hôpital édard erot à Lyon une première
mondiale en matière de chirurgie a été
réalisée par une équipe internationale
composé de spécialistes en
microchirurgie orthopédie et chirurgie
de transplantation l'opération a
consisté à implantter la main d'une
personne décédée sur un homme de
nationalité australienne qui avait été
amputé à la suite d'un accident c'était
en 1989 il s'agit donc pas d'une greffe
mais bien d'une réimplantation dont le
succès ne pourrait être vérifié bien sûr
que dans plusieurs mois voici en
exclusivité les images de cette
opération avec les explications de
Benoît Gadret et Jean-Daniel
fzquier Clint Alam vient d'entrer dans
l'histoire de la médecine il est le
premier à avoir reçu la main et une
partie de l'avant-bras d'un donneur
décédé emputé en 1984 après un accident
de tronçonneuse il a été opéré hier à
Lyon par une équipe
franco-australienne pendant 13h sous
microscope les spécialistes ont rabouté
entre le greffon et le receveur les
veines les artères et surtout les ne
FIB avant d'être
opéréint
sonmotion être le premier Greff de la
main je vis avec
humilité bien
pass va très bien on est très content on
avait de très grands sourir mais il
faudra de long Mo pour savoir si la main
réimplanté peut exécuter tous les gestes
de la vie quotidienne